Imagine no possessions.
I wonder if you can,
what would a world without money look
like? Would society be better off?
Would it eliminate greed or hunger?
Would we be happier?
How would you get the things you need?
This is what if,
and here's what would
happen if we had no money,
dollars, cents, savings,
debt. Like it or not,
this is our society today,
but it wasn't always that way.
Several thousand years ago, we were a
species of hunters and gatherers tracking,
foraging, keeping only what we
could carry. But along the way,
we started experimenting with agriculture
and learned how to grow our own food.
We stopped moving and settled down,
forming organized communities.
Life got easier, but we still wanted
more than we had. So we began to barter.
Fast forward a few thousand years
to the first minted coin in 600 BC,
cash became king.
And today money's still does the talking.
So what would you say if the
world suddenly went broke?
Okay,
understandably, it isn't easy to
imagine a world without money.
So we went ahead and did
the hard work for you.
One thing is certain looting and crime
would skyrocket. Humans have needs.
We get hungry, we get
cold, we get jealous.
Law and economy normally
keep these drives and check,
determining what we can afford
and what we can get away with.
But suddenly everything is lost.
Its value and whoever's job it is to watch
the goods or maintain order no longer
has an incentive to do so. No one wants
to work for free without paychecks.
We lose important services. No police,
no fire department, no doctors,
no military. And what about technology
powers and free, neither is running water,
definitely not gasoline and Ditto
for cell service and the Internet.
So our world would be thrown into a dark
anarchic chaos in this survival of the
fittest scenario.
Gun Owners would fare the best and it
would be in their best interest to band
together to claim a greater
share of resources at lower risk.
With humans forming into factions,
we can already begin to see a
repetition of early sedentary societies.
The streets would no longer be safe.
You'd have a high chance of being
ambushed and anything worth taking would
likely already be under armed watch,
so humans would establish stationary
communities in fortified positions.
They may send teams out to raid nearby
communities or established partnerships
with neighbors. We'd have to
reestablish the barter system only.
It's harder to do in modern society.
Early civilization had fewer commodities,
making fair trade easier,
but since we're used to so many
different goods and services,
it might be difficult to
establish a proper exchange rate.
It's not simply a matter of trading
apples for oranges is a granny Smith worth
as much as a blood orange? What if
apples organic and the orange is GMO?
What protections would we have against
counterfeit goods and how could you save
for the future if everything
in the market has a shelf life?
These are only some of the concerns that
we've more or less resolved since the
introduction of currency,
but maybe a world without currency would
be an opportunity to restructure our
society
today.
We produce enough food to feed everyone,
yet people still go hungry and there's
enough shelter for all of us to sleep
soundly. Yet. Some of us are homeless.
Without money we might learn to be
comfortable with less. Without fortunes,
there'd be fewer,
less fortunates we might enjoy working
freely for a greater good. Of course,
a better world doesn't have to be a what
if scenario through trade we've learned
to cooperate and when hard work pays off,
we're encouraged to innovate.
The challenge then is to improve upon
the existing system and empower more
people within it.
Do you think we can do it?
Where should we start a penny for
your thoughts and pay it forward
a penny for your thoughts
and pay it forward
only it's harder to do.
In modern society,
early civilization had fewer commodities,
making fair trade easier,
but since we're used to so many
different goods and services,
it might be difficult to
establish a proper exchange rate.
It's not simply a matter of trading
apples for oranges is a granny Smith worth
as much as a blood orange? What if your
apples organic and the orange is GMO?
What protections would we have against
counterfeit goods and how could you save
for the future if everything
in the market has a shelf life?
These are only some of the concerns that
we've more or less resolved since the
introduction of currency,
but maybe a world without currency would
be an opportunity to restructure our
society
today.
We produce enough food to feed everyone,
yet people still go hungry and there's
enough shelter for all of us to sleep
soundly. Yet some of us are
homeless. Without money,
we might learn to be comfortable with
less. Without fortunes, there'd be fewer,
less fortunate. We might enjoy working
freely for a greater good. Of course,
a better world doesn't have to be a what
if scenario through trade we've learned
to cooperate and when hard work pays off,
we're encouraged to innovate.
The challenge then is to improve upon
the existing system and empower more
people within it.
Do you think we can do it?
Where should we start a penny for
your thoughts and pay it forward?